It's our last Friday.
Did I hear an, "Oh?"
Thank you for that one "oh."
It's OK.
I'll take what I can get.
It's our last Friday, and so
next week is our last week.
We have class on
Monday, and Wednesday
will be the last class.
And we've got one
more smallish topic
to cover after this,
which is diffusion,
and we'll wrap up on Wednesday.
But today, I want to keep
talking about polymers.
So this is our polymer week.
And I want to go back
to the properties
I've put here, the properties
we've talked about.
Right?
So on Monday, we focused
on what a polymer is,
and we focused on
the ways you make it.
All right?
The radical initiation, chain,
addition, and the condensation
polymers that you know,
the condensation where
you have two different mers.
And then on Wednesday, we talked
about things that matter, kind
of like engineering polymers.
Like what are the properties
of the polymers that you
can change, that we can change?
All right?
And so we talked
about, well, you
could pick a different monomer.
That will change the properties.
Right?
We've been through that.
You could try to grow
longer or shorter strands,
so that's going to
change properties.
The interactions
between the strands,
which will, of course, depend
on what you pick there.
Right?
And then we talked about the
density and the crystallinity
and how that could
depend on things
like cooling rate, or maybe
the physical structure itself
of the chain.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, when I say
physical structure,
of course I mean
the chemistry that
makes that physical structure,
so I could branch the chain
with the same monomers,
but now instead
of being one linear chain
it's a bunch of branches.
Or maybe you could
have a functional group
that you can control which
side of the chain it's on.
And all those things
would lead to differences
in density an crystallinity.
And then the last thing we
talked about is cross-linking.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to add one more thing
to this list today,
but before I do that
I want to pick up
on the last slide of
Wednesday, which is this.
So we tend-- so all this
kind of goes in together
to give you these
solids called polymers.
Right?
But we talked about
how sometimes they're
not fully solid,
and that's what's
going to come in the middle.
But you can make a
solid thermoplastic,
which is these strands.
Right?
So what is a thermal?
Ah, what's the?
Anyway, so with thermoplastic
we'll look over here.
There is no cross-linking, so
you don't have any of this.
But what do I have?
Well, I have these
really long strands
that are bonded together
with these IMFs,
typically in a
thermoplastic you would
have something like
maybe van der Waals,
and maybe you have some H bonds.
And these materials, because
you didn't cross-link them,
and you didn't
cross-link them strongly
with some kind of strong
bond, because of that,
you can reheat them
and reprocess them.
So these are actually
often the plastics
that we recycle
that we can recycle.
And like I said, they're mostly
linear and maybe slightly
branched polymers,
and they're used
in a whole lot of applications,
so we call them thermoplastics.
Thermal-- you can heat them.
Right?
You can heat them,
and you can see
what happens is if I
heat these back up,
these links can start moving.
They wiggle, and they wiggle
until they can just kind
of slide past each other
and become a vicious liquid
and then a melt.
On the other hand, if
I've got a thermoset,
I heated it up, and then as
it set I crossed linked it.
And there are lots of
ways you can cross-link.
We talked about some of those.
Right?
And now I've got a pretty
high density of cross-links,
so that's drawn here.
So I've got these long strands.
Remember, they're super,
super long, right?
But now, every so often I
have something linking them
together.
And if I put a lot
of cross-links in,
and if they're
strong cross-links,
then you can get
really hard plastics.
Right?
And so these are high--
the thermoset, they're set.
They're set.
Thermoset, good.
It solidifies, and
it can't be reheated.
Why?
Think about it.
If I heat that up, then, OK,
I might melt the polymers,
so the chains are kind
of wiggling around,
but those cross-links
aren't going anywhere.
They're really strong.
And so what happens
with thermosets
is they're very
difficult to recycle.
They're very difficult to
recycle because what'll happen
is before those things melt
the whole thing catches fire.
The whole thing catches fire.
It burns often.
Or maybe it doesn't burn,
but when you melt it,
you've got this
weird chemistry now
of the cross-linker
mixed into the polymer,
and it's not useful anymore.
So these kinds of plastics--
the cross-link is really great.
You make, you know, like I
said, over 30% of all toys.
It's used in many,
many applications,
these harder plastics, but
they're not recyclable.
And then, we talked about
this intermediate region.
And this is where we ended.
We talked about elastomers,
and elastomers are in between.
And so in an elastomer, you've
got light cross-linking.
And the cross-linking,
like in slime,
that cross-linking has
a weaker hydrogen bond.
All right?
And remember, we
talked about how
that could lead to
viscoelasticity, really
cool stuff.
In other cases, like in the
case of the vulcanized rubber--
remember that, Charles Goodyear?
That story from Wednesday?
In that case, you
put a covalent bond
of sulfur between the
strands, and that gave you
a much stronger rubber that
still had some elasticity.
But now, the best analogy
here is still the spaghetti.
I keep coming back to it.
I'm not letting go.
Think about it.
If I've got a bowl of
spaghetti, and I pull on it,
that's my plastic
bag on the left.
All right?
That's my plastic bag.
I pull on it, and
those chains are all
crumpled up and tangled,
and I'm untangling them,
and then I'm sliding
them past each other,
and pulling them until
the whole thing rips.
That's the bowl spaghetti.
But now I've got this spaghetti
that attaches every so often,
one strand to another.
Think about it.
I've got a bowl spaghetti, but
in each strand of spaghetti,
there's like five places
where it's attached
to another strand of spaghetti.
Now what happens?
I can pull that as well.
I can pull it because
those spaghetti
these are all curled
up, and so there's
some amount of pulling
that I can do while they
uncurl until those
links take over,
and I can't pull past them.
All right?
That's what the light
cross-linking will do.
And you say, well, if I
had heavy cross-linking
in the spaghetti, then the
whole bowl of spaghetti
wouldn't be very easy
to move because I'm
always up against all
the links between them.
All right?
And so that's why these
elastomers are so interesting,
because they fall--
it's all interesting.
But the elastomers
fall in between,
where there's some of that
uncurling of the polymers
until you get to a point where,
depending on how much you've
cross-linked, and the
bonding of the cross-link,
you're going to go up
against the cross-linking.
All right?
And so these are used,
so they're free to move.
Now, must be above its glass
transition temperature.
I want to talk about
that for a second
because I did
mention this, and I
want to be sure that we all
have a good sense of what
that means.
And so I wanted to--
taking this elastomer,
say, what happens
when you melt it?
All right?
And we drew this curve, but
I want to go very carefully.
This is the temperature.
Oh, we love this curve,
the molar volume.
Right?
And now up here,
you've got your liquid.
Right?
We know that.
And then here is the place
where it would crystallize.
Can a polymer crystallize?
Sure.
Right.
If a polymer
crystallized, then it
would just be these
strands in a crystal.
What is a crystal?
We know it's a repeating
ordered structure.
Yes, polymers can crystallize.
But as we've talked
about so often, what
happens is because, like we
talked about with silica,
you know, you've got this
very viscous, amorphous,
can't find the crystal sites--
same with polymers.
And so you get a glass.
And then this was the Tg.
Now, why am I showing this?
Because with these strands--
and I want to show you.
You know, we've drawn this
before where often what you
get in polymers is some degree.
It's right here, some
degree of crystallinity.
Right?
So what do I do?
How do I do this?
Well, you literally have both.
All right.
So I've drawn this already.
So if I'm here on
my polymer, then it
might look like what I've
drawn already on the board.
Oh, I love doing this.
And then there's the crystal,
and then there's more.
I've drawn this already.
Right?
You've got this
crystalline region,
so you've got the
crystal, and here,
because I'm below the glass
transition temperature,
this part here is an amorphous--
oh boy, it's kind of small, but
this word says "amorphous"--
solid.
It's a solid.
That part is a solid because
it's below the glass transition
temperature.
All right?
OK, but now let's
start heating this up.
And as I get to the--
so now I'm going to get here.
And what happens is
it doesn't actually
go straight to the full liquid.
I mean, it's got this
crystalline stuff in there,
right?
It's got these regions.
This crystal has
one melting point.
Remember, the melting
point of the crystal
is the melting point
of the crystal.
It doesn't change.
Glass transition
temperature can be tuned.
But this is a melting--
Now, so what happens.
Well, what happens is there's
more of a curvyness to this,
and you might kind of have
the shape look more like this.
So what's happening?
This just gets a little
bit more at the detail
of how a polymer
would melt if it's
got any crystalline regions.
And as I've told you,
very often it does.
Not always-- it could have
no crystalline regions.
It could be totally amorphous,
but I've drawn this enough
that I wanted to explain
this curve with that
as our starting point.
All right?
And I've also talked about how
the degree of crystallinity
is so important for properties,
and it can be controlled.
So what's happening?
Well, in this region here--
let's draw that picture.
So now I'm in here.
And what happens is I'm
below Tm, but I'm above Tg.
So that means that, literally
in the same strand--
this is so cool.
That looks the same.
It's not supposed to be the same
because now this is a liquid.
This is a viscous liquid,
and this is still a crystal.
That's an xtol.
I'm below Tm.
So the crystalline
region has not melted,
but the rest of the polymer
is above its glass transition.
This is so cool.
This one strand is both a
solid and a liquid, one strand.
That's so cool.
That's in here.
All right?
And then I get over
here, and now here--
OK, well, let's see.
So now this is all liquid,
and the crystalline part
is starting to come apart.
So crystal melts, xtol melts.
All right, well,
that sort of was
supposed to be the
remnants of a crystal.
And then above Tm, the whole
thing's a liquid, right?
So that's kind of zooming in.
I wanted to make sure
that we understood
this plot in the context
of these polymers.
And that also
gives you a sense--
OK, now, that's this one strand.
Now, I've got a
bunch of strands.
Did I connect them or not?
And that adds the layer
of what an elastomer is.
Right?
Because now you can
imagine, is the elastomer
above or below Tg?
Where's is Tg?
Are we above or below Tg
when we bounce a ball?
Right?
How does that influence
the properties of the ball?
A rubber ball is
likely cross-linked.
And you can imagine
that if you're below Tg,
then all that amorphous
part of the ball is a solid,
so there's an elastic response.
Sure, it could still bounce.
If you're in this region,
then that part of the ball
is a liquid, but it's
likely cross-linked
so the ball doesn't fall apart.
Right?
So it's going to
bounce differently.
Right?
It's going to
bounce differently.
OK, so anyway, I
wanted to just go
into detail of that to make
sure that we feel our oneness.
And I mean, you could add here.
This is, because it's
so important in just--
like I was saying, just in
terms of what this material, how
this material behaves, you
could add the glass transition
temperature, which, as
we've already talked about,
has a number of ways
that it can be tuned.
On the other hand,
it may also be
tuned by some of these
other things that you do,
but it's a very important
part of the polymer property
ecosystem.
OK.
Good.
So that's the elastomer.
Now, there's one more
thing that we can
do that I wanted to talk about.
Oh, that's the picture.
Yeah, I thought I'd show
you another picture.
So I'm not the only one
that draws things like this.
All right?
OK, there's a nice one from
Encyclopedia Britannica,
and you can imagine this
region being a solid down here,
then a liquid.
But that's still solid,
and then that region
melts all at once at Tm.
The last thing
that I want to add
is another way that we have
to control polymer properties,
and it's another bullet here,
and it'll be our last one.
And it's really the
composition and sequence.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, it turns out that--
remember when we
did condensation.
Right?
Polymerization, a poly
condensation it's called.
The condensation polymerization.
We had two different mers.
And we could have
picked the box.
Remember, the box inside the
mer could be different things.
And then when we've done
the radical initiation,
we've just had one mer
with the double bond.
Right?
Now, if you have
one mer, then that's
called a homopolymer, Homopoly.
And if you have two,
it's called a copolymer.
The thing is that we actually
can even make copolymers
with both approaches.
And not only that, but
we're learning more and more
how to control the sequence,
and that's what this shows here.
So I could have a polymer A.
Let's say I have a--
yeah, I'll put it below this.
Let's say I have a, you know,
polymer, polyethylene, PE,
which is-- oh, we know
now how to draw these--
C, C, N. And then I've
got the other one, which
is PVC polyvinyl chloride,
and that looks like this--
C-- all I've done here is swap
out a hydrogen for a chlorine,
and I've got a totally
different polymer.
All right?
Some other end, OK?
And an N, whatever.
I can now alternate these.
I can alternate them, and
I could alternate them
in this way.
So PE might be my A,
and PVC might be my B.
And if I alternate them,
we might-- you know,
if it's like
regular alternating,
we might write PE--
this is how we'd write
the copolymer-- a, PVC.
All right, but you could
also have it be random,
so then you'd write PE--
you can take a guess-- r, PVC.
Right?
You could write a
grafted version--
PE, g-- well, you
get the point--
PVC, and so forth.
What I mean when I
write this is that I've
taken these two polymers,
and I've copolymerized.
I mean, sorry, these two.
Well yeah, these
are the polymers.
I'm taking the
monomers, and I've
made one polymer out
of the two of them,
but I've controlled
the sequence.
It's not--
Now, maybe it's not controlled.
Maybe it's random right there.
Or maybe I've figured out
how to do this in a way
that I have the
backbone all one type,
but I can have
these side chains,
the branches, another type.
That's really
powerful, it turns out.
Or maybe you can control that I
have a certain number of them,
and then a certain
number of the other,
and this is called
a block copolymer.
And some of you may
have heard of block
copolymer chemistry,
which is growing,
is a very growing,
very powerful field.
Because when you
make these blocks
and you control
their properties,
you can imagine that you
control all sorts of things
about how that polymer behaves.
Imagine you make something
that bonds to A but not B.
Like dissolves like.
All right, we've been there.
B is something that
bonds to B but not A. OK,
what's going to happen?
They're stuck, but
they're going to try
to come together and stay
apart in the same strand.
All sorts of interesting
things can happen.
It can be engineered
when you can control
these blocks or these graphs.
All right?
So that's the last
thing that we--
Here's an example.
This is-- I was trying
to look for a good exam--
here's something called--
actually, what is it called?
Surlyn.
Who comes up with that?
I don't know why that's the
name, but that's the name.
It's the Surlyn resin,
which is the ingredient that
goes into the polymer, OK?
And look at what it does.
Oh, it provides clarity,
toughness, versatility.
Surlyn is a leading choice for
food, cosmetic, medical device,
skin, stretch, packaging,
as well as golf balls.
The tunability is enor--
why?
What is Surlyn?
Well, we don't know exactly
because they won't tell us,
but Surlyn is
actually really cool.
It's using-- OK, it's using--
where?
Dah!
Where did I put it?
Composition, sequence--
it's using sequence
to make a graft polymer
where one type is
going along the chain and
the other type is coming out.
But really importantly,
the other type
is made specifically
to form ionic bonds.
So here B is made
so that it can form
ionic bonds with other parts.
Ionic, remember, that's
basically by grafting,
by creating a copolymer,
where one type wants
a form ionic bonds.
I've cross-linked.
I've made a cross-link built
into the polymer itself.
The cross-link is going to be
linking the strands together,
maybe within itself,
maybe with other strands
but with an ionic bond.
Right?
But I've done it all just
built into the polymer.
And that's why you can see here.
Look at this it's an
ethylene copolymer.
All right?
So ethylene is the backbone.
The co is what's
coming out of the side,
and that's an ionic bond, so
it's also called an ionomer.
What's an ionomer?
A polymer that has ionic
cross-links, ionic bonding
cross-links.
And what's cool about that?
Well, you get the whole world
of ionic bonding now in the mix.
And so what does that mean?
Well, you could have it
be very strong, golf ball.
You can have it be
thermally responsive.
Right?
You can tune at what
temperature these bonds break.
There's all sorts
of flexibility,
and you can see it right here
in how they're marketing it.
It can do almost anything.
Another example
of the copolymer--
I'll give you a couple
examples of copolymers.
This is one that you may
have seen, maybe many of you
experienced, you
just don't remember.
This is the diaper.
Right?
And so what what a
diaper is is it's
got this copolymer made
out of acrylic acid.
These are the monomers.
Notice the double bonds?
Oh, we're going to take
advantage of those,
and we're going
to make a polymer,
but we're going to do it
in a controllable way.
So we're going to
take these two mers,
and we're going to control
how they come together.
And very importantly in
these kinds of materials--
they're broadly
called hydrogels.
These are materials that
can absorb hundreds of times
by weight, hundreds of
times water into them.
Why?
Because in one of the copolymers
you've got this sodium atom,
and what happens is
there's the dry state.
It's all curled up and the
chains want to be all together,
but as soon as you
introduce water,
those sodiums like
going into the water.
And what happens?
They leave behind this oxygen
that really wants the water
because it's a negative charge.
And so you get a sodium
ion going in the solution.
You get the solution
coming to the anion .
And even more than that,
now if the sodium leaves,
then what happens?
Well, what happens is all
those negative charges are left
and they repel each other.
That's going to help this
whole thing want to expand.
Right?
So that's a diaper, 2% of
all landfill by the way.
Now, so that's another
example of a copolymer
and a really interesting way
of tuning the properties.
In here it has to do
with, what did we do?
We tuned the ionic
character of the backbone.
We tuned the charge.
We made it responsive it
in terms of its charge
to something, in this case
water, the presence of water.
That's cool.
OK.
Last one, and here I want to
talk about mechanical strength.
So this is the tensile strength.
So how far could
you pull this thing,
this material before it breaks?
And then here's the
elongation until it breaks,
so it gives you a sense.
Now the tensile strength,
this is how far can you
pull it in the elastic regime?
You can see that for
steel it's really high,
but you can't pull it
very far before it breaks.
We know that, right?
So steel is really strong,
but it's not very flexible.
There is nylon.
We did nylon, so it's kind
of not nearly as strong,
but it has a lot of elongation.
There's fiberglass.
This is plastic
reinforced glass,
where you can get
a lot of strength,
very little flexibility, more
than steel, a little bit more
than steel.
Well actually, it
was a lot more,
but still it's only
3% or 4% elongation,
and here's cellophane.
That can be a naturally
occurring polymer.
You can also make it
synthetically in the mix.
And I want to point out nitrile.
Nitrile rubber is a really
interesting copolymer,
and many of you may have seen
or used-- if you're in a lab,
you might use nitrile
rubber gloves.
You might have them
at home at the sink.
And one of the advantages
of nitrile rubber
is, again, this enormous
tunability by just picking
how you copolymerized.
How much of one did
you put in the other?
And this is-- maybe
I'll use this board here
because it's a really cool
copolymer, where you're
putting in acrylonitrile.
So here's what this looks like.
So you put your CH2, your
CH, your double bond your CH,
your CH2, and there it is.
And that's going to repeat
some number of units
that you control because it's
a block copolymer before you
put this one in,
and here's the kick.
It's got a triple
bond nitrogen on it.
And that's going
to go a certain m.
All right?
Now, that comes from
acrylonitrile and butadiene,
but again, it's the synthesis
to make the copolymer.
It's the sequence.
I keep on forgetting where.
It's up there.
It's the composition,
the architecture.
How did I put those copoly--
if you do this in
the right way, it's
the amount of the
acrylonitrile that you put
in will control the strength.
It'll make it
stronger and stronger,
because you've got this really
nice, strong bond in here,
and this will give the
material a lot of strength.
So that's why you can go up to,
you know, fairly reasonable.
But then, how much
of this I put in
is going to determine how
far you can stretch it,
and so you balance those.
And you can make a whole bunch
of kinds of nitrile rubber.
OK, so I hope this has
given you some examples
of the tunability of polymers.
And you know, if you
take the bigger picture--
and this is a
little hard to read.
You know, it will
be in the slides,
so you can look up
this paper here.
It was published in
Science a few years ago--
and you look at the
fracture toughness
with the yield strength.
So what is that?
Well yield strength is--
Remember, we know
that because it's
when you're in the elastic
region, and you're pulling,
and then you yield to
plastic deformation.
Right?
That's the yield strength.
Now what about
fracture toughness?
Well, that's if
you start a crack,
does the thing tend
to crack more or not?
That's the fracture
toughness basically, right?
And so you could put
materials down on this plot.
You've got ceramics.
You've got concrete down here.
You've got-- so you're
not going to be.
So the polymers sit here.
All right?
Here's metals, and
alloys, metallic gases.
You can look at
this on your own,
and look at each one of those,
but I just want to point out,
polymers have a
fairly wide range,
but there's so much
interest in going beyond.
There's a lot of interest
in using polymers
in many other applications.
We can't get there yet
because we can't push it
out here or maybe out here.
We still need to figure
out how to tune it more.
We've got all these ways
to control the properties,
and we're still only at the
very beginning of understanding
how to engineer polymers.
Now, there is no better way
to make that point clear
than to look at nature.
All right?
And I already
showed you the tree
and you know, the examples of
nature as a polymer engineer.
I want to talk about that a
little more because nature
is not just a polymer engineer.
Nature-- I'm going to
write this down nature.
Nature is a polymer
engineer gone wild,
and I'll show you why.
Polymer engineer.
Humans, what can humans do?
Well, we are a natural polymer
engineer material, but what can
we make with all of what
I've just shown you?
What can we make?
I can put like
one, or maybe two,
or if you really go
into the research,
you get three mers,
trying to control
where they are in the chain.
All right?
You've got three, maybe two.
We have really two
in most materials.
Copolymer-- we're so
proud of this nitrile.
Two mers, and we control them,
and we make rubber sheets.
But nature-- but then
they're everywhere.
They're everywhere is just that.
All right?
So nature can have--
so humans have the same
functional group every stop.
All right?
OK, that's one mer.
Maybe I've got two,
maybe two or three.
Nature can have different
groups, and here's the key.
It can have them everywhere.
OK?
So what I have is I have
many, many more possibilities.
I mean, we have these
possibilities too,
we just can't control it.
All right?
So if I look at--
like let's go back
to condensation
polymerization because this
is what nature does.
So this was what I
drew for you on Monday.
There's a dicarboxylic acid.
Here we're making nylon.
And a diamine, and
we're making polyamide.
And remember, the box--
in nylon 66, the box
is 6 carbon atoms.
I call that boring.
It's at six carbon
atoms from hydrogen,
but that's kind of boring.
But in nature, this
box is an amino acid.
That's much more interesting.
That's much more
interesting because if you
look at an amino acid, and
this is an amino acid--
why is it an amino acid?
Well, it's got an amine group
here and a carboxylic acid
there, so it's an amino acid.
But see, here's the thing, R.
This is nature's "the box."
We can put six carbons in.
We're really proud of ourselves.
Nature can put almost anything
it wants for R. All right?
So R, just to spell this
out, is nature's choice,
and I'll show you
what it chooses.
Nature's choice-- because there
are hundreds of amino acids,
and this R group can do many
things, but just 20 is all we
need to make proteins.
Most proteins are made out
of just essentially 20.
But if you do the math--
I think I have the math here--
and you take-- let's see.
OK, if I take two amino acids.
Let's say I take
two amino acids,
so I've got two different R's.
Two amino acids, and
I've got a length is 2,
and this is called
the dipeptide.
I'll tell you why in a sec.
OK, but let's compare this now.
Now I've got 20 amino acids, and
I just told you that 20 is what
nature makes most proteins
out of, 20 different R's.
There's an amino acid.
R is nature's choice.
But see, if I've got 20,
then I've got 20 squared
equals 400 dipeptides.
I've made a two-unit polymer.
It's not a polymer.
It's a peptide.
But now, what if I take
the 20, and I've got--
but now I've got, let's
say, 1,000 units long,
then I would have 20 to the
1,000 possibilities, which is
10 to the 1,300 combinations.
So 10 to the 1,300
possibilities--
that's because
there's 1,000 units,
and I've got 20
amino acids, right?
But now you think,
how do you possibly
think about what to do?
That is nature.
It's had 1 billion
years, and it's
given us the world that
we live in, that we know.
It's messed with
these combinations
in a way that's impossible
for us to even understand.
That's why I say, nature is
a polymer engineer gone wild.
It's got almost limitless
flexibility, and it's used it.
Right?
Now, how does nature
make its polymer?
Well, its condensation
polymerization.
This is just what we saw.
Look at that.
This is what an amino acid is.
It's got this
carboxylic, so there's
the OH group that can
condense with the H
here and form the link.
There it is.
That's called a peptide bond.
When two amino acids come
together, that's a CN.
That's a peptide bond.
Right?
But look, this had R1.
That had R2, and I've got
20 different amino acids
to choose from.
The possibilities are endless.
So the protein synthesis
is condensation pol--
you knew that.
You knew it couldn't be
anything else because there
is no double bond.
Where would I have done
a radical initiation
with these amino acids?
If I'm nature, I've got to
make it with condensation
polymerization.
That's how we are made.
OK, now, so just to give
you a sense, so the R--
I'm not going to go
through this, obviously.
I'm just giving this
to you as if you
want to read more about it.
There's some wonderful
charts here, 20 amino acids,
the 20 that are most common
and that nature puts together.
And what they've done
that's really nice
here is they've
grouped them, right?
Because what did
nature choose to do?
How is it most utilizing the
properties, the tunability
in these amino acids.
I said there were 20,
but most proteins are--
I'd say there are
hundreds, but most proteins
are made from these 20.
It gives you the tunability in
having maybe non-polar groups.
Right?
So it might be then hydrophobic.
Polar groups, hydrophilic--
maybe you can put,
nature can put, R groups in
there that maybe have a charge,
or that lose or take an ion.
All right, so it can
play with the charge,
and it has done all of that.
It can have groups that become
acids, that make something
acidic, and so forth.
OK, so that's cool.
What has nature done?
Well, I got to show you
this spider because--
and if you're interested,
Professor Bueller
does some wonderful
work on spider silk--
because I think this is a
great example of something
that nature can do that gives us
a sense of how far away we are.
Like I said, we're very proud
of this, and we want to do more.
And so we take our two mers,
and we mix them together,
and we make branches,
and maybe we're
going to try to add a third.
Meanwhile, nature has had a lot
more flexibility and a lot more
time.
What can it do?
Well, here's spider silk.
Now, this is a spider.
Spider is an incredible
polymer synthesis machine.
It's an incredible
And here it is weaving
a web, and I love this--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--because I think it's so cool.
OK, there's music, I guess.
I forgot about that,
and there it is.
Now watch.
Out of here, this is
the back of the spider.
There it is right there.
It's making protein.
That's called spider silk,
but these are proteins.
These are polymers.
It is doing condensation
polymerization right there,
and then there's all sorts of
structural stuff that it does.
Right?
It's got a specialized hook.
It knows how to step.
It creates-- look at that.
There's a branch place
where it knows to put it.
Right?
It's already created the glue.
So not only is it putting
this spider silk out there,
but it can put other
types of polymer
depending on what it needs.
Does it need something
really sticky, less sticky?
Right?
And so there it is
weaving its web,
and it's generating
this polymer on the fly.
It's doing condensation
polymerization.
Now a couple properties
about spider silk.
OK, so here we go.
Let's see.
So spider silk, this is just one
example of what nature can do.
It's five times
stronger than steel.
Remember the mechanical
strength chart,
nothing was stronger than steel.
Spider silk is five
times stronger.
Just to give you sense, the
example, I found that I like.
If you had a spider silk
that was a pencil width,
and you made a strand, it would
stop a Boeing 747 in midair.
That's how strong it is.
Oh, it keeps strength--
here's another thing-- below
40 degrees C. We can't do that.
Just take a rubber ball and put
it at that low of a temperature
and try to bounce it.
It's going to shatter.
Right?
Spider silk can keep that
strength and not break.
Its elastic, so it's got--
throughout all of this, it's
got an elastic property of 4x,
so it can be stretched to four
times its original strength.
Compare that with nitrile.
Nitrile rubber could
also go to very, very
high elastic elongation.
All right?
So if you go back to nitrile--
here it is in the table.
We're very happy with
this, but this only
had two monomers to play with.
Right?
We played with two monomers,
and we got to here,
and look at the sacrifice
in the strength.
Look at how much we had
to sacrifice strength.
Spiders don't have to do that.
OK, and oh, here's the last one.
Fully recycles-- now the
thing is that this is actually
kind of incredible.
Spider webs get dusty.
They lose their stickiness.
So many spiders know
this and just simply
have to weave a
new web every day,
but they don't leave
the old web there.
They actually eat it, and
they fully recycle it, fully.
Right?
They eat the web, fully
recycle it, process it,
have this condensation
polymerization work,
and make a new one the next day.
All right?
So we don't come
close to this spider.
We don't even come anywhere near
it in terms of where we are.
Even though I gave you
all these wonderful things
that we're doing
with engineering,
we still have so far that
we could go if we could just
figure out how nature works.
OK?
And this gets me to
what we do, and so I've
got my "why this matters" now.
And so a spider eats its
web, fully recycles it,
spins a new web the next day.
Here's what we do
with our polymers.
I already talked
about the oceans.
Here's what we do on land.
These are tires.
Now, tires are very
difficult to recycle.
Why?
Because they're too vulcanized.
They've got too much cross-link.
Remember, if the cross-link
density is too strong,
which you need to make a tire,
then you can't recycle it.
And in fact, what happens is--
and there's a tire mound.
Here's it is from a
satellite picture.
Those are tires.
Those are tire mounds.
Here's what happens
when one catches fire.
when many catch fire.
All right?
It's actually a very hard fire
to control once they catch.
But we don't really
know how to recycle them
well yet.
What can we do?
On the science and engineering
side, the fact of the matter
is there is a lot of
work to do, but there
are promising directions.
So I wanted to leave you
with a little bit of that,
and I'm not going to
go into great detail.
I just want to show you,
and there's references here
you can look.
This was published a couple
of years ago in Nature.
One direction is in
self-healing polymers.
This is a very
exciting direction.
What can we do?
Well, we can go away from
this whole single-use idea
and make stuff last longer.
All right?
So that would be beneficial.
Maybe not if it ends
up in the ocean,
but in terms of just how long
we can use these materials.
So one direction is, well,
you've got these polymer
networks, and you incorporate
little gels, little beads
in here, but the
beads don't open up
until a crack comes along.
So they're sensitive to a crack.
And when they feel a crack in
the material, they open up,
and they pour a healing
liquid that then solidifies.
That's a self-healing
kind of approach.
You could do that
at different scales,
all the way down to the strand.
You can do that
on larger scales.
And here's a whole system
where there's actually
this healing material being
flowed through a polymer
structure, just like
arteries in our body.
Again, always there to
try to heal the material.
Right?
Another direction is
in fully recovering.
And again, I don't want to
go into full detail here.
You can look up
some of this stuff.
This was published last year.
Can we take the
polymer and chemically
decompose it all the
way back to the monomer?
Can we go back to
where we started?
Can we do what the spider does?
Right?
The answer is no, not today.
But if we could,
that would open up
a whole lot of
doors for recycling
that are closed today.
Can we do this in a
way that is efficient?
Right?
And then, another
direction of work
that I think is
very important is
in making thermosets so
heavily cross-linked so you
get all the hardness and
all the properties you need
of the polymer that's heavily
cross-linked, but easily
breakable in the cross link.
And there is good work
going on in this direction.
Can we make
degradable thermosets?
That's another really
important direction.
And last, we should
be encouraging people,
if you can't do any
of this, at least take
the polymer out of the landfill
and make something with it.
And there are projects-- you can
look at here, Waste Management
Journal, in making
bricks out of polymers,
incorporating them into
construction materials.
Right?
These are important directions,
and we need a lot more
hopefully in the very near term.
No more just talking
about alignment.
OK, have a good weekend.